qui veut le croissant le plus plat de
l'histoire je croise ans est passé de
ceux de voitures petit déjeuner de 300
[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous sommes au studio de
l'olivier dans un grand fond blanc et on
tourne mon court métrage s'appelle
d'apport du sommeil
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette porte et la porte du sommeil qu'on
a fait construire par des très très bon
décorateur et chaussées content c'est
exactement ce que j'imaginais action bon
tout est à refaire
plus tu terrain et moi tu pourras entré
et j'ai le décor
[Applaudissements]
je vous présente camille est une amie
comédienne qui va jouer le rôle de mam
et donc voilà on partage un peu le lit
dans ce film sauf que moi je suis un
druide insomniaque
elle dort comme un petit comme un petit
bébé je sais pas vous mais normal et la
wii comédienne s'il vous plaît svp
[Musique]
chaleur des tropiques qu'est ce que ça
te fait que la personne la plus
chanceuse en cas de sous c'est vrai que
je suis chanceux pour une fois en
caleçon et en slip en dessous attention
j'arrive à l'abri du vent le talent et
on est prêt merci ce moteur
alors là on fait un plan très important
dans l'histoire c'est à dire que tout
d'un coup j'ai réussi à évacuer les
mauvaises idées
les mauvaises pensées et l'insomnie
disparaît et donc forcément les portes
de sommeil s'ouvre à la manière de
jurassic park fameux plan ou quoi les
deux grosses porte s'ouvre et voilà les
centres et 2
les voitures dans le parc des dinosaures
[Musique]
cette personne est mal aux cinq ans
acteur professionnel qui joue moi quand
j'étais petit à malo alors par contre on
prend des petits kimber chocobo
l'alliage du monde 1
est ce que tu me parles bonbons s'est
jamais arrivé de retrouver un objet des
comptes était petit sauf que maintenant
tu peux lire ce qui est écrit dessus
quand je dis j'avais la même voiture
mais je ne savais pas que c'est qu'il
construction dessus je voyais juste un
sigle l'aveu peuple à aller là je suis
actuellement avec isabelle et sam qui
sont aux deux comédiens de qualité qui
jouent mes parents voilà quand j'étais
plus jeune il faut également de la
musique ils ont un groupe qui s'appelle
à mini vague je suis oublier à l'écouté
1 3 2 1
let's go
avec mon couteau l'homme poteau 1 c'est
vraiment un homme photo ont dépassé par
comme ça sac à main levée qui fait le
mauvais instrument
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monsieur une fin de tournage
[Musique]
à